I was like oh we were talking about boy
boy Wescoe the boy westcoast you know
when when the [ __ ] did that pop off all
right am i behind on this I really like
a little right now and yeah it's
definitely like like getting like to
like being a big meme right now okay it
is yeah it's almost blowing up in the
meme scene yeah yeah now boy boy so I
was saying this earlier but it's crazy
because fools gone wild used to post him
a shitload and it was just like a funny
thing and like they would use the song
for like random posts and so like some
posts they would use his face other
posts you just knew the song and then
like some minecraft
meme page on Instagram I picked it up
and I remember like looking at my phone
one day and I just hear it you was a big
blow and then like the Minecraft like
character is like like puts in like a
pixel and starts backing up and it's a
gigantic like in Minecraft portrait of
[ __ ] boy boy westcoast I'm just like
holy [ __ ] and then the tic-tock like
parodies started happening and then
that's when it like really took off its
dude it's unfuckin real how much impact
tick tock has now on music dude I'm
thinking we just make 15 second snippets
of joke songs until like one of the
[ __ ] pops I mean the and then make
the whole version yeah I mean I just
post them on Tech Talk I mean that's the
that's basically that I'm [ __ ] rich
[ __ ] no I know but like we didn't mean
to yeah exactly yeah like well upload it
on purpose yeah it's like [ __ ] yeah I
[ __ ] with that just plant the seed
trying to blow the [ __ ] out just
co-signing my conspiracy of using
tick-tock oh yeah music but now it's
even more than ever like now this
[ __ ] kid that did that Western
countries are assigned a [ __ ] record
deal insane there's a picture somewhere
I forget where it's a major radical all
right show this that's gonna be the next
move on the next TMZ project once we
drop it you all gotta go - tick-tock and
just make hello
[ __ ] parodies of whatever it is like
non-stop until one of them goes viral we
are going viral baby yeah we are going
viral I'm gone viral I'm going viral
yeah you don't even of in the club there
are
it was like a handful here I want to
play this one yeah what other actual if
you don't know the hell we talking about
what you should yeah cuz you know what
wait West Coast is kind of mainstream
now I mean he kind of he kind of is he
was like a niche like fools gone wild a
meme for like a minute cut did that a
kiss that yeah hit the mainstream I'm a
little bit you know I don't really focus
Tremont different it's like yeah we're
[ __ ] with him like back yeah way back
when he was underground so yeah yeah I'm
saying that I just I don't be [ __ ]
with memes that make it to read it you
know I mean I'm not wait now speaking of
memes will play play this and I do daily
Ram riddles did a remix so it's like boy
boys verse which is just like nope it
will get give everyone like the full
yeah get the guitar
[Music]
[Music]
he does his verse which is like yeah
everyone says I look like this dude Owl
City hello
[Music]
ooh
yeah this is so our city it's crazy yeah
I mean but it's weirdly a hit no I know
that's not really a hit yeah
so speaking of ending that country song
has so that the country rap song it has
if you go on Spotify has 33 million
plays in sand then all the rest of his
songs have under a million so crazy this
is that crazy looking crazy that songs
gonna go [ __ ] platinum or go gold I
mean we surely will we should have put
on [ __ ] rich on Spotify we still can
we still can but I don't think it's
gonna have the same no no I didn't go as
as viral as that now it's not as big as
that I mean we could you know you can't
manufacture that [ __ ] we'll try it and
see what happens but speaking of [ __ ]
memes that there's like a something that
started with like everyone thinks the
ending of Avengers is ant-man is gonna
go on Thanos [ __ ] and go gigantic and
kill him that way and like to the point
that the writers of Avengers like
acknowledge that they're like law I know
everyone thinks that ant-man is gonna go
in a nose [ __ ] but that's not how he
dies really and then he like offered
like a different version of it like what
was it like going in his ass and then
like like getting so big and putting
Thanos in his ass and then shrinking
back down he's gonna get so big and just
sit on Tanis and then get really small
and like that would kill them both
though yeah but like you know he'd
sacrifice himself okay well ready for
like and not that I gone read it or
whatever yeah yeah there was just a
[ __ ] eight hour period where it was
just hell just ant-man like in the
[ __ ] memes like like it was so funny
how like they had burned the the premise
so bad there was one it was like Winnie
the Pooh just crawling out of a hole and
the
titled it man I don't know anymore and
it's just like like ant-man Thanos
[ __ ]
this is anything and everything that
could be someone crawling in someone
took this is Larry someone took a clip
of Shaq from hot ones and colored him
purple and then like a like rotoscope
like the lines of Thanos chin okay on
his chair is like they notice when
ant-man goes in his [ __ ] and he just
like he's like eating the wings I so and
then that's it it's so good yeah
mium economy is real man get big bro
yeah that's this whole thing oh he can
change size yeah you didn't see the Paul
Rudd and man movie no I didn't I thought
it I was forced to watch it and ended up
being kind of entertaining forced like a
ton point yeah damn yeah some dudes
broke in my house they're like watch all
the Marvel movies no just ant-man yeah
watch it oh right just great and it was
like the no jumper [ __ ] but it was just
with movies exactly ran in with the DVD
of that and [ __ ] um Shanghai noon
with Jackie Chan that's a great movie
yes in before someone says that's you
and me Shanghai noon I gotta look it's
Owen Wilson and Jack oh yeah yeah bro
boy boy West Coast man you was at the
club how is he real man - what do you
mean I was a mustache everything
everything man his moustaches look like
looks like it looks like it's painted on
yeah it's perfect it's perfect
and then he's got this giant tattoo on
his yes that's like where he's from yeah
he's like the crate he was just like the
movements in that video oh yeah
everything a violin everything it's so
robotic it is he's he's like he's an
animatronic troll oh man Boston Dynamics
actually made him dude
they made him he's the first animatronic
cholo yeah Boston Dynamics like so this
was our next big project
just boy boy West case it's like rocking
left and right
it was Oh fool you was at the club we
have different vocal tones for boy boy
voice is insane dude oh yeah you I can't
even do it that's its strangest [ __ ]
everyone on girls gone wild call them to
like Kermit the Frog ass like they're
like roasting the [ __ ] out of those
[Music]